há vários anos atrás quando eu assisti a
um filme de super herói minha mãe pegar
uma toalha de rosto dois grandes de
roupa em gravar minhas costas
naquele momento eu era super herói
exigindo meu corpo que eu podia pla mais
alto correr mais rápido os vizinhos eram
todos os mutantes crianças agente
secreto e eu me escondia no pé de ameixa
esperava o momento certo para salvar
minha família do rodo da vassoura falar
na garagem então dominar o mundo
depois da brincadeira acabava e eu
voltava pro mundo normal mas o mundo
normal não é tão cheio de aventuras
os juízes fazem todas as mesmas coisas
eles vivem as mesmas vias como se fossem
todos os figurantes e quando eu via uma
cena cheia de figurantes e gostava de
inventar a história que eles tinham aqui
cabisbaixo ele queria ser astronauta e
mostrar pro mundo como o mundo é bonito
mas é alguém falou para não viver no
mundo da lua aí o trio fez um concurso
público e hoje ele trabalha na caixa
essa aqui olhando nada é maria nasceu
pra ser artista
mas hoje ela resume a vida e limpar a
casa que o rodeava senhora porque a
tinta e pincel ficar para trás em algum
momento na adolescência sabe essas
histórias que eu cresci vendo um monte
de sonhos e boas intenções que ficaram
pelo caminho pra caber naquele padrão da
sociedade que disse estudar para tirar
boas notas vai para uma faculdade que dá
dinheiro arranjou um emprego seja
estável faz um concurso público encontra
alguém que tenha a coragem de te namorar
cria filhos e garante que vão fazer o
mesmo que você fez e morre
só que na tv não passava o filme do
tonho da maria passado nilce cara que
tinha uma arma apontada para a testa
desviava da bala que era um super herói
a conexão dele com os princípios tão
forte que ele tava de prédio passava as
pessoas mudavam o mundo dele por sair
desse fluxo era o cara que eu queria ser
quem era eu naquela época eu era ronan o
cara quer conquistar o mundo tocando
guitarra mas que aí deixou tudo para
trás
não dá dinheiro eu me perguntei qual é a
diferença entre o tonho e uniu porque as
histórias que me inspiravam estava nos
filmes mas não tava na minha vizinhança
que eu precisava pra fazer para chegar
naquele super-herói bom comecei a olhar
os super heróis
primeiro de tudo mil o cara é um
escolhido e uma profecia atrás dele eu
nunca fui escolher pra nada
quando eu jogava bola na escola os
capitães tirar para o emprego para que
perdia ficava comigo e começava
escolhendo beleza não podia ser um nível
próximo super homem forte voa
eu tentei um dia subir em uma cadeira
poder pagar a minha mãe não alcancei
abri meu queixo em 2008 quando faço a
barba lembro que eu não vou
o fruto do senhor dos anéis é mais
parecido comigo é baixo ele é fraco e
não voa mas ele carrega no peito
artefatos mais poderoso do universo eu
carrego comigo celular ea chave de casa
não tenho nada mágico mas aí veio a
descoberta se você não tem uma profecia
não voa não tem um artefato poderoso não
te preocupa o que eu descobrir que pode
transformar em um super herói é na
verdade um sanduíche de frango
vou explicar como mas vou contar uma
história lá em 2010 eu fundei com alguns
amigos mas filial de uma organização não
governamental em joinville chama a esac
ela existe no mundo inteiro ea gente faz
é fantástico a gente leva jovens para
outros lugares do mundo e lá desenvolve
um trabalho social ou profissional e
essa experiência fazem com que eles
desenvolvam uma nova visão de mundo e
competências de liderança agora se faz
isso redor do mundo com muitos jovens e
o resultado que você prepara toda uma
geração para aumentar o seu impacto
positivo no mundo 2011 eu era presidente
desse comitê em joinville
a gente está fazendo estava indo muito
bem pra quem eu comentei que tinha
acabado de começar
só que essa história pra mim estava por
terminar no final do ano outro
presidente entrar no meu lugar e eu ia
voltar a ser um estudante universitário
tentando terminar a faculdade pra
arranjar emprego assim como a maioria
assim como tonho
quem está feliz com isso a minha família
lógico que sonho não para ter um filho
engenheiro mecânico era a primeira
pessoa da família e com uma faculdade
faculdade o primeiro lugar meu filho não
querem falar pra mim
o dia já estava no escritório vendo um
mapa que dizia todos os países em azul
que faziam parte da esac e na américa do
sul tinha um buraco quero paraguai
e aí alguém soltou um comentário assim o
chá do tão certo né gente trazer um
exemplo para uma cidade imagina aqui
doido seria levar para um país
completamente diferente naquela hora o
coração bateu mais forte o braço
arrepiou é como se tivessem topo da
montanha russa tomando a respiração
antes de cair por toda uma queda livre
mas era aquela ideia que os meus pais
chamariam de receita para o problema
afinal de contas quem é desequilibrado
suficiente para deixar tudo para trás e
se mudar com o país e voluntário por
tempo completo foi contra um amigo e ele
me falou
vamo vamo meu lanche eu escolhi meu
favorito num sanduíche de frango e aí
comecei a cara tem sonhado levar exemplo
outro país com o paraguai mas sabe a
idéia certa ou errada não fala espanhol
termina a faculdade não tem dinheiro que
sem ninguém do paraguai não sabia nem
como começar
ele falou rapaz você conhece a história
do hércules
imagina se fosse de um cara muito forte
mas que recebeu 12 trabalhos que era
maior do que o potencial que ele
imaginava que tinha e ele falou algo
humano é muito difícil
o topo até você vai fazer uma faculdade
na rehgião emprego quem lembraria a da
história desse cara que diferença vai
fazer no mundo mora depois estava em
casa o computador aberto além dos passos
que eu tinha que dá pra levar 0 no
paraguai mas era segredo de estado
se essa informação vazasse para quem
morreu na hora
o primeiro ponto a primeira tarefa era
escrever um estudo sobre o potencial do
paraguai e receber essa organização eu
fui até curitiba tem uma aula com
professores tudo pra ganhar décadas foi
tudo ótimo na volta de casa bateu o
carro
como é que eu vou esconder isso
um amigo meu pagar pelo conserto do
carro ninguém ficou sabendo
o segundo passo depois que o projeto
pronto era apresentar esse projeto a
todas as autoridades internacionais da
asec inglês em uma conferência no quênia
em duas semanas
agora eu não tinha dinheiro nem para ir
nadando para o quênia
mas se você quer ter uma solução
apresentei esse projeto com os diretores
da universidade e qual foi a minha
felicidade quando eles falaram que me
apoiar a compra das passagens e antes de
ir embora um deles apertou a minha mão e
falou já tomou as vacinas está tudo bem
com um passaporte
eu não tinha passaporte
a fila mais curta era de dois meses
o coração saindo pela boca comecei a
ligar pra todo mundo que talvez pudesse
me ajudar
até que eu cheguei em alguém que
conhecia alguém outro que a filha e um
primo do amigo do vizinho de alguém que
conseguiu uma vaga na na fila do
passaporte eu chegasse no dia seguinte
na delegacia antes das seis da manhã
três dias depois eu estava olhando pela
minha mãe ea minha foto em um documento
internacional pela primeira vez no ano
seguinte estava olhando pela janela
linha turbina girando sentindo a pressão
do corpo contra o banco enquanto o avião
decolava para cruzar o oceano pela
primeira vez nessa missão secreta
apresentação do projeto foi um sucesso
o aplauso das autoridades internacionais
é que teve condições de vitória
mas a missão tinha acabado por aí eu
estava sozinho e eu precisava de uma
equipe de outras pessoas tão
desequilibrada as quanto queriam deixar
tudo para trás se mudar comigo pro
paraguai para começar essa aventura
agora encontrar esses desequilibrados do
mundo não é tão difícil difícil
encontrar quem queira o paraguai
eu sabia que eu tinha que fazer esse
pessoal amal país
antes mesmo de sair pra lá então criei
uma campanha no facebook onde jovens do
mundo inteiro é uma foto segurando uma
plaquinha dizendo que ela apoiava o
projeto dá à da implementação da esac no
paraguai foi feito barulho enorme gente
do mundo inteiro mudou sua foto
dentro de pouco tempo o projeto tinha
nomes longa música poema investimento
financeiro um mês antes de me mudar para
o paraguai
eu já tinha minha equipe quer burlá las
junto comigo construir seu sonho desde o
zero a ii estava perto de dividir de
realizar tudo aquilo que eu tinha
sonhado era momento da minha família
fica sabendo eles não sabiam e era por
uma razão o esforço que eles tinham
feito a vida inteira pra me dar uma
educação de qualidade a expectativa que
ele tinha de ter um filho engenheiro
mecânico que balançava
se até agora os desafios tem sido
difícil e eu não tinha parado
neste momento as coisas eram diferentes
agora uma coisa que vocês precisam saber
que o meu pai a pessoa mais radiante que
eu conheço o cara vai comprar pão no
mercado ele encontra cinco amigos no
caminho três carros buzinam ele faz mais
dois amigos na volta
só que aquela época ele estava com um
problema de saúde era forte o suficiente
para apagar aquele brilho dos olhos ea
única coisa que dava energia pra ele
é a perspectiva de que o filho dele é
formar engenheiro mecânico no ano
seguinte eu estava pronto para jogar um
balde de água fria
naquele momento eu quis voltar no tempo
e não tem de tão longe num projecto e
facid chegou eu falei tá bom eu não vou
fazer isso mas eu já plantou a semente
eu sei que daqui pra frente a alguma
outra pessoa vai continuar e vai vai
construir a esac no paraguai mas eu não
posso fazer isso
abri o computador e aquelas fotos do
quênia via foto dos jovens que enviar
aos pouquinhos falei foi bonito aqui
fechei os olhos é a primeira coisa que
veio na minha cabeça aquele sanduíche de
frango e aquela conversa sobre o
hércules chegar bastante longe do
computador foi até o sofá a mãe temia
voz falhava eu sentei do lado do meu pai
ele pra ele fala aí ai' mês que vem eu
não vou morar aqui em casa eu não vou
nem morar no brasil e paraguai
eu vou para a faculdade e eu vou pra lá
e vai exec como voluntário por dois anos
e meio de todas as respostas que eu
esperava receber do meu pai
talvez o silêncio era a única que não
tinha planejado é mais dolorosa
um mês depois estava no ônibus cruzando
a ponte entre foz do iguaçu cidade do
oeste mala cheia de roupas a cabeça
cheia de preocupação mas o coração
aquela certeza de que estava seguindo
meu caminho e ali o sonho começou a
acontecer a nossa equipe recrutou os
primeiros voluntários gente fez o
primeiro projeto e várias histórias
fabulosas começaram a sair dali
histórias como a da tio que era uma
menina muito tímida mas que participou
de um projeto alcançou resultados
excelentes e descobriu que tinha um
potencial que além do que ela imaginava
tomou coragem pra montar uma empresa
para vender os bônus que ela fazia na
cozinha de casa e hoje no dia de hoje
até no méxico ensinando crianças de
escolas tudo que ela aprendeu nessa
jornada 5 matthew nesses dois anos e
meio
outros 70 jovens tiveram essa
experiência de ir para muito longe para
mudar de vida e voltar pra casa pra
começar a mudar o mundo e daí pra frente
eu comecei a viajar assim mais passei
por mais de dez países fazendo
treinamentos e contando essas histórias
produtos pessoas que também queria
implementar essa idéia um dia voltando
de uma conferência da hungria eu liguei
pro meu pai e para minha família para
dizer tudo que tinha acontecido toda a
história tinha passado e eu lembro
daquele dia como se fosse hoje
meu pai lá no telefone do outro lado do
mundo atravessando o oceano me falou que
está muito orgulhoso do que você fez
eu sei o quão difícil foi seguir os seus
sonhos e agora está construindo coisas
com as próprias mãos é só coragem de ter
seguido esta jornada foi o que me deu
mais felicidade me deu energia pra
vencer aquele problema de saúde que eu
tinha um suspiro do coração
o som estava realizado a vida dos jovens
do paraguai estava mudando para um
pouquinho melhor a minha família entende
o que está fazendo eo meu pai estava bem
missão cumprida
de todas as pessoas que gostam de
história super heróis não sou o único
existe um homem existia um homem que
faleceu chamado joseph campo eles do
mitos e heróis por toda sua vida
escreveu um livro que chama o herói de
mil faces e mais interessante que ele
descobriu é que há uma uma coisa em
comum entre
todos os mitos e heróis que inspiram as
pessoas desde o hércules até uniu do
atrix é o harry potter
o que há em comum entre todos eles é a
jornada todos os heróis passa exatamente
pelos mesmos passos
a história do herói começa um lugar
comum e é uma pessoa comum
até que um dia ele recebe um chamado
para a ação é uma carta de hogwarts é um
velho mago aparecendo a cada entrega um
anel poderoso fala se que a coisa mais
poderosa do universo pega tpu o que
acontece com o herói naquele momento é
que ele recusa
esse chamado coração e fala não mas eu
sou uma pessoa normal não sou ninguém
especial algum outro evento acontece que
faz com que ele decida seguir em frente
e um herói deixa seu mundo e passa por
um mundo desconhecido onde ele encontra
ajuda de um mentor em com e começa a
enfrentar vários desafios que os faz
mais forte até que o momento enfrenta
crise pior medo da vida dele o grande
vilão nesse momento herói cai em várias
histórias ele inclusive morre mas é só
para que ele possa renascer levantar
como ser evoluído e vencer o medo que
ele tem
naquele momento ele encontra um tesouro
é um reconhecimento conhecimento alguma
coisa que ele ganha com essa jornada e
ele volta pra casa pra compartilhar esse
tesouro com as pessoas que moram lá é um
ciclo ataque começa a próxima aventura
agora nessa aventura que eu passei eu
também encontrei o tesouro dentro dele
encontrei três princípios que eu aprendi
sobre todos os super-heróis
o primeiro deles é esteja no limite do
seu alcance
o autor stephen covey do livro os 7
hábitos das pessoas altamente eficazes
introduzo um conceito do círculo de
preocupação é o lugar onde estão todas
as coisas que o que você quer que seja
diferente mas você não alcança o
crescimento global corrupção no total o
governo a o trânsito da cidade
o que acontece se você coloca todo o
tempo e energia em algo que você não
pode mudar mas que você quer que seja
diferente
o melhor que pode fazer é reclamar aqui
está o tonho compartilhando coisas no
facebook dentro do circo tem o menor
tinha círculo de influência são as
coisas que você pode mudar um projeto
junto à comunidade voluntário ensinar
jovens algum tipo de esporte
a mágica quando você coloca o
a energia que atua influência cresce
aqui tá uniu ele começa o desafio
pequeno que pode fazer agora e
eventualmente chega a mudar o mundo
número dois o fundo do poço fica no meio
do caminho o herói atingir a sua vitória
somente depois da crise somente depois
clicar e rocky balboa no primeiro filme
treinar o filme inteiro ele chega na
luta com a pole leva porrada do cargo
ele cai ele perde a luta e ele vai pro
hospital ele fica duas semanas no
hospital que ele faz depois hospital e
volta pra casa faz uma faculdade pois há
emprego não se é o tonho rocky balboa
treino e volta por rende desce a lenha
no cara e aí ele era do cinturão no
final
agora se você está no seu projecto na
sua jornada e negócio ficou preto
muito provavelmente é um indicador de
que está no caminho certo número 3
atenda ao chamado a eu quero ser
empreendedor eu quero ser um artista eu
quero viajar o mundo mas não tenho tempo
e não tem dinheiro eu não sou uma pessoa
especial
cada vez que você recusa um a um chamado
à ação um herói morre
aquele que mora dentro de você como
seria o mundo se a gente tivesse mais
pessoas que fazem e as inspira que sai
desse fluxo da sociedade vão para
aventuras enfrentar seus medos volto pra
casa e dizem olha que eu aprendi e olha
que eu ganhei eu voltei pra compartilhar
meu tesouro com vocês
você nasceu pra ser um super herói que
as próximas gerações com tem a sua
história
isso depende apenas de uma coisa a
diferença entre tonho e uniu não é um
superpoder é uma decisão a de atender o
chamado por ação
mas preste atenção na simplicidade o
portal que pode te levar para o mundo
dos seus sonhos pode não estar no
artefato mágico mas em uma conversa com
um amigo comendo um sanduíche de frango
muito obrigado